you're right
good morning -- the rules
committee meeting for Wednesday
April tenth twenty nineteen is
hereby called order please be
advised that audio and video
recorded today's proceedings
be maintenance all sweet
a man sector please call the
roll Cooley here Cunningham
Carillo here flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove Maienschein
Mathis quirk Silva
Ramos three of us Wicks here
we have a quorum and we have
a consent agenda most like
senator move a muscle check
out of our Mister Ramos --
-- this call the roll Cooley
hi Cooley aye Cunningham
Carillo I Carillo aye flora
Grayson Grayson mine cam
water drive Maienschein
Maienschein aye Mathis Mathis
I for social quirk Silva I
Ramos Ramos I read this works
hi work side motions passed
in the schools committee is
in charge thank you very much